If you wanted to on Andrew, you just had to listen and not break
toos. And you could have done this to his face. Richard, break
to I'm on the show and he's not. What does that tell you? >> Andrew
Wilson's got 100 times your audience and I want some of that
audience and you're a loser for ruining my chance to get that
audience. >> I'm sorry I lost my temper and called him
the f-word. But that's what I think of him to be frank. [music]
>> Oh wait, there is one other thing that I had for tonight
and we might check this
Apparently, there was some debate that was supposed to happen
between Richard Spencer and Andrew Wilson, and it kind of got
cancelled. This is three days ago. We have Andrew Wilson and
Richard Spencer. They're supposed to have a red pill debate.
It kind of goes off the rails pretty quickly. >> Andrew
Wilson and Richard Spencer
debating the Manosphere. We have two topics. The Manosphere is
number one.
Richard Spencer will have his opening statement which will be
about five minutes and then we'll give it to
Andrew
and uh and then we'll go back and forth crossfire
um Richard whenever you're >> Okay. Thank you Andrew for
being here and thank you Josiah for inviting me and setting this
up. So I believe the topic uh or my affirmation is that uh the
manosphere is a socialist movement
uh for low status losers in order to get is that what it is more
or less.
>> Um you can read that. >> Sure. Manosphere. >> I
don't think that's true. It's
it's like uh dude, it's the manosphere is just DGG for people
who are right-wing,
right? Like you basically are a total loser. You've got a little
bit of money, but you're a total loser
and you've given up on everything yourself, so you just give
your money to somebody else who is like fairly disgusting, shares
some of your political views and does,
right? I think that's a far more accurate description is you
want to live vicariously through somebody else so you give them
your money and attention so you could do that,
right? I think I think that's more what the manosphere >> Okay.
Slash men's rights movements are socialist egalitarian crusades
made up of men that need to be eliminated from the gene pool.
>> Well, that's even harsher than I remembered, but uh
wow. And then the next one is that so-called traditionalists
want to return to an era that never existed. They actually don't
want to return to the past. They want to return to a magical
utopia, basically.
>> Okay. Um I think I can handle all of these and I'll
try to keep it at five. Um but if I go into 10, maybe you'll
give me that time and I'll I'll certainly give that time to Andrew
if he needs that long to respond as well. It's I think it's best
just >> Well, I think we have the structure down. It's
like uh five five and then how what is it? three three four minute
rebuttals I think >> these two things so let's just have
a discussion I mean uh we're not playing tennis here um so >> I'd
like to keep it to the format otherwise we >> end and uh
I'm the reason why this debate is happening so I'm let's keep
it to the format I'm the reason why this debate is happening
I I don't mind Richard Spencer he actually is like um this is
completely given that like the this the
difference in how much money they Like I just Andrew can walk
away from most things. He's a Nazi. Spencer. Spencer's not a
Nazi. He's racist. He's not a Nazi. If anything, he's like a
white nationalist as a LAR. I'm not even joking. Like he's he's
like racist, but he's basically a liberal.
Like he's not a fascist, right? He's basically a liberal. His
his views are not that far out anymore.
And I think when he entered the spotlight originally, it was
in a way that wasn't super aligned with his own personal values
or thoughts to be honest with you. He's changed a little bit,
but he really wasn't that racist to begin with. It was like a
thing where he got to be more racist because it got him like
clicks and views. It got him like clout, but he really wasn't
that racist to begin with. >> Or he wasn't that authoritarian
to begin with. At least in terms of what he advocates for. >> Then
you can off.
>> Are you in charge, Andrew? Yeah. Yeah. >> Are
you in charge, buddy? >> I am. >> No, you're not.
Josiah's in charge. >> Uh, Richard, we did >> we
Well, we agreed to talk platform, and if you don't want to do
it, then don't do it.
>> Uh, no. I'm going to speak for 10 minutes. I'm going
>> somewhere else for 10 minutes.
>> Listen, Andrew,
you man, you are the when [laughter] I
OKAY. OKAY.
Everybody said it should be censored. Let's see if it's actually
censored. When I imagine like losers being attracted to the manosphere,
it's you, buddy. >> I know. I know. You got me, Richard.
>> he did get you. All right. >> You got me.
>> Thanks for agreeing with me, Josiah.
Oh, Richard's like crashing out. Richard's getting totally mogged
in this moment. Richard's like totally mogged right now. He's
He's already like cortisol spiked massively. It's basically over.
I'm gonna speak for five to 10 minutes. I'm gonna say some interesting
things. >> I disagree. Allow Andrew. >> Can we stick
the format? >> The for We're not playing tennis here. I'm
going to give >> No, we're having a structured debate.
Yeah. And we're having a structured debate and we agreed to a
format and I'd like to stick to it.
>> Oh, I I'm not going to back down on >> Then then
go away. >> I'm going to speak for Why don't you go away,
you little
>> Oh, no. Rich, >> they did cut it. Okay. He calls
him the fsler there. You little f slur. >> Richard, let's
keep it 5 minutes. No slurs, nothing. You can seriously sabotage
both of our lives by doing >> I'm going to speak for a
reasonable amount of time. >> Oh, no. >> I will allow
Andrew to respond and I'm not going to be timing him or something
like this. Okay,
that's what's going to happen.
Do you agree with that, Josiah?
>> No, I do not agree with this. We have the five minutes.
I think that structure makes sense. It's best >> I um I
actually I actually can't anyway. He already broke the toos.
I already got to reboot the stream. So like that's that's the
end of that. Appreciate the time, guys. >> Damn it. >> Yeah,
he's running away. He's running away. He did. They did the exact
same thing to our >> No, Richard, we literally started
this. We started this and the first thing I said was literally
no slurs.
>> Oh, I'm sorry, Josiah. Let's just do it again. But like
that guy is so annoying. I can't even put it into words, >> dude.
No. Oh my gosh, bro. This has been two weeks of planning, Richard.
Two
>> Well, then why don't we I get I get feeling pretty pissed
as the person who's trying to host this and then
the big the big name just like goes away.
Oh, it's rough. This guy's name is Josiah. Josiah. Yeah. >> We
have a conversation. I'll do it live. You don't need Andrew.
He sucks. No, I Okay, my audience loves Andrew. Andrew does a
phenomenal job here,
dude. H I'm going to have to apologize. >> He did the exact
same thing to RFH. They don't want to debate
it just
so
I know that Oh, it's Andrew's wife had a debate with RFH, right?
And it ended up getting cancelled because she wouldn't cam up
or something.
Is that is that what that's what happened there? Right. I think
that's what happened back a couple weeks ago, maybe a couple
months ago even.
All right. Now, this happens. I don't know how long Richard's
around for. We'll listen to a reasonable amount of time and I
will allow him to have his time as well. I'm This is the most
reasonable thing on earth. >> Yeah. No, I Okay, I understand.
But dude, the Okay, the structure was 5 minutes, right? I know
you said 10 to 15. I said this is the structure I'm thinking.
You agreed to that and then Andrew I sent >> I don't care.
We're not playing tennis. Josiah, I'm gonna speak. I want to
finish my statements.
>> No, I I understand that. I I get it. But at the same
time, it's just this is like, you know, when you say something,
he doesn't want to be blown out of the water. So, they do this
like technicality. Do you honestly think I fear debating Andrew
Wilson like in the slightest bit? >> You honestly think
that? >> I think you were extremely bad faith when the
the guy because dude, the first thing I said was, you know, YouTube
terms of service. >> I'm sorry I called him up. This is
a channel, okay? I spent a ton of money on this channel. >> This
is YouTube terms OF SERVICE. I'M SORRY I CALLED HIM a cuts. [laughter]
>> Okay. Okay. And this is >> start over. I will
begin talking. If Andrew wants to reenter, then he can do that.
[snorts] >> I'll give you my time since I'm here. >> Like
this is ridiculous.
>> Yeah. I I >> try to say,
you know, this is how it works. And you know, you can say it's
been I'm correct. He's not like I I not doing this. All They
have been extremely reasonable and like the Andrew Wilson runs
away like the little weakling that he is and I don't know what
to say. I will give a opening statement to your YouTube audience
if you would like and we could have a discussion for an hour.
But like this is not like this guy is just he's such a it's a
posos. Look at him. >> I I I like Andrew. He's been extremely
charitable to me and my family and >> he's not actually
a good person. He's he's a like dork and doofus period. Okay.
So, let's not pretend like he's some cool guy.
>> Okay. Where is Where does all this tension come from?
Is this come from uh the RFH beef and with Rachel Wilson or something?
You have like >> I I have contempt for both of them just
on a personal level to be brutally >> I wish I knew this,
man. I It totally >> to them. I don't have an axe to grind
with either of them. All right. I just despise them. >> Man,
I knew it was going to be an interesting debate because you guys
disagree on axiomatic principles. So, I wasn't figuring we would
get to a to a middle ground here, but damn, dude.
>> That's brutal. >> Josiah, you got to be a moderator
and not just take like five. >> I mean, just like said,
I'm going to conflate both things into it 5 to 10 minutes, then
he's going to speak. We're not playing tennis. You don't need
to >> serve whatever. And I'll I said I'll
>> a meme in my Discord.
>> What is wrong with that? >> Yeah. Um, it it really
is uh it really just comes down to simply the the >> Just
skip to the killstream. I'm going to go to the killstream when
I'm goddamn ready to shut the up >> that we made. Right.
If >> Okay, I I'm out. Josiah Josiah, you have got to be
I'm going to teach you something. All right. You have to learn
to be reasonable with people. You It's agreement. What I said
I I suggested something 10 to 15 minutes. You came back and I'm
like, "Okay, let's go." All right. It's not like we signed a
contract in blood. I am asking for 5 to 10 minutes so that I
can get my thesis out there and then I will give him whatever
time he needs to respond within >> Right. This is how reasonable
people
>> Yeah. Okay. So >> there's no we're not playing
I I don't know how is he trying to cope and be like well I'm
actually reasonable after the fact when I sp the out. He totally
he totally spurred though. Come on man. Richard just spurred
out. I don't know why. Tennis for the third time. >> This
is a debate and there's an eb and flow. I'm going to attempt
to uh uh once again do a little bit more of a moderate. Don't
get don't get upset with me, Richard. But when we have the rules,
the five minutes and just I'm out. I don't want to hear I'm not
sure. >> I'll give you an hour. I don't want to hear one
more thing about how I'm not playing by the rules. I have been
the most reasonable person. >> Okay. All right. You want
to give your uh 10-minute rant on uh the red pill >> It's
not a rant, but yes, you can jump in anytime you'd like, Josiah.
Um, so >> dude, I >> the [laughter]
>> Uh, okay.
So-called manosphere emerged in the
But what what do men want? What what is who are we? What is an
expression of true manliness and masculinity? For a loser like
Andrew Wilson, he wants to be given a woman and he wants to be
given some employment that he feels will give his empty life
meaning etc. uh and so on. That actually has nothing to do with
manliness or masculinity. That is a
>> is he just not actually looking at reality at all? >> Again,
a rather mid 20th century middle class fantasy uh from low status
males. Andrew Wilson being a prime example uh of this reality.
What does it mean to be a man? It means to sail. >> Doesn't
he literally have a wife and kids and like a pretty high income
for somebody in his position?
What What are we talking about here? This just seems really weird
that you're going to put this on Andrew when he has all of the
things he's asking for. Like all the things he thinks should
be like the basis for life,
he has already.
How could this apply to Andrew Wilson?
Does he have kids? Yes. pull your ships >> I think at least
one of those kids is his. No, he has adopted kids too, but I
thought he has his own kid too. >> Waters. It means to
found the Roman Empire on the basis of a quest and a great the
of the sabine women to go out and do it to grab them by the as
it were. Women are the most essential resource and real men go
out there and get it. And only a select few of men are brave
or bold or strong enough or fit enough in a Darwinian sense to
actually achieve this. And the rest of the men, to be frank,
don't reproduce and die. Again, the manosphere is a socialist
eal. I don't think this actually is true. I don't think that's
ever been true. I think there's like a lot of uh genetic studies
that show this broadly isn't true. You needed like to get to
the Mongols to make this this remotely true, right? And then
even then it's like not really a survival of the fittest like
a Darwinian thing. It's literally the people who have like a
accumulated power. Alitarian movement to the extent that it wants
to change this fundamental aspect of human nature and >> Yeah.
He's he's looking at this. I don't think this is actually a fundamental
aspect of human nature
at all. I don't think this is the way humanity's like ever worked
in any Darwinian sense. >> Fundamental aspect of mascul.
Am I crazy or was that not something during the all of these
discussions that like hypergamy really isn't the standard state
of things at all? I'm pretty sure that's just not like the standard
state. Like not even hypergamy, the like polygamy state of things
where multiple women go to one guy. I don't think that's ever
really been the state of the world. I'm pretty confident that's
not the case. Like even in um
like
at what point in Europe has it been the
I don't think that's the case.
Uh I can remember a great documentary that is narrated by David
Adamo called Life and it um it goes through all sorts of reproductive
strategies and one of them that stuck out to me was the Dawson
bees that are these sort of earthn bees that uh burrow into hives
and once a year what happens it's mating time and the women the
female I shouldn't say women the female bees present themselves
above the earth and all of the male Dawson bees engage in a ferocious
orgy of violence in which they are attacking one another. Most
all of them perish in
this is like a totally analogy.
I Okay. Uh okay. We don't need more. I don't need anything else
there actually. Thank you, Richard. Thank you. Bees. We're like
bees now. That's worse than
Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. I'm not I'm lying. We're actually going to go
>> He actually goes way harder. No, >> if you wanted
to on Andrew, you just had to listen and not break to. And you
could have done this to his face. >> break to. I'm on the
show and he's not. What does that tell you? >> What do
you mean >> that he has higher status than you? You like
are desperate to get your message out and Andrew left cuz he
doesn't need this. Dude, I Why Why is Richard Spencer making
me defend Andrew Wilson? I don't even want to.
>> I mean, I'm still here talking. He ran away. So, what
does this tell you? >> It tells It tells me that Andrew
is a >> He left because I broke to >> Yeah. It tells
me that Andrew is a smarter businessman than me cuz I my stream
is in jeopardy. >> He's a smarter businessman than you.
>> Yeah. So,
think about this, right? If I came into your job and was like,
"Say say the n word. Say the n word. Say the n word. Say it."
Right. And then you said it like you actually could lose your
job, right? It's kind of the same thing here on YouTube. Anyways,
this is like uh this might be beyond the point, but I'm sorry
I lost my temper and called him the f- word, but that's what
I think of him to be frank. So, and who ran away like a little
girl? Who did that? Did I do that or did Andrew do that? Which
one of us did that, Josiah?
>> Yeah. I mean, there's a qualifier here, which is that
there like the terms of service. You know, Andrew is extremely
>> Terms of service.
>> Okay. Give me a break. Josiah, he needs to stop saying
to
he needs to say what it is. Tell him Andrew Wilson's got a hundred
times your audience, and I want some of that audience, and you're
a loser for ruining my chance to get that audience. You're a
You have nothing. You are worthless to me. This conversation
is worthless. That could have been worth something. The conversation
between the two of you two of you could have been worth something.
A conversation with just you is worthless. You are worthless.
You're the low status here.
That's all Josiah needed to say, but he doesn't want to say that
cuz he also probably is lower status than Richard. So, I I'm
like moments away from leaving. I'm sorry, but like this is just
>> But then who's going to run away like a little girl
then though, Richard? You're you're stuck in this room with me
now. >> I'm about to grab you by the way. Do >> you
want to offer some sort of interesting comment here? >> Uh
yeah. No, I mean I think I just did.
>> You didn't
see real masculinity from Andrew as well? Because you know how
difficult it is to adopt a child that's not your own blood and
to actually love them as your own. Do you know what type of sacrifice
and humility that takes?
>> Josiah, what are you talking about? >> You don't
you think that's >> why would anyone want to do that? Because
I can understand that you do it in certain circumstances, but
I mean this is not some adopting someone else's child. It's not
some ideal. No, one of their children died due to neglect. Not
due to >> I'm not sure these are great parents to be honest.
>> What are you talking about? That's what I've heard doing
some basic research. you've heard wrong and and you're you're
smearing a family who who is who's been through the ringer and
you're >> like if honestly if this was coming from a place
of
somehow in my head somehow in my head this would be less cringe
if Richard Spencer just hadn't been fighting was just like starting
and throwing
it's because he got so emotionally disregulated that now he's
doing this that's what's so embarrassing about it is like he's
actually hurt and he's trying to hurt this person back,
right? Like he it's so weak. It's just like a move.
That's what's weird about this to me is he's not doing this from
like a place of strength. He's not doing it like, "Oh yeah, this
guy, this guy like on some in some passing whatever. He's not
doing it from a place of stability. He's like emotionally disregulated
and kind of losing it. And now he's just like, did you know their
kid died due to a neglect?"
>> Saying that this is their ringer. their child died and
you're saying it's because they neglected their child. Richard,
do you know how >> that's what her other husband claimed?
>> Uh, okay. So, so >> I don't know. Doesn't he have
a point of view in this? And he'd be right. >> I don't
know. >> No, I Why you say that? >> Because because
that's not how this works. I know somebody who went through the
same exact situation in Arizona. They went out, they were underage,
they were also drinking, not legally able to drive, ran a red
light, and one of them >> their young child was hanging
out with the wrong crowd and her basically, if I remember correctly,
was the story. >> It can always be the wrong crowd. Rebel
Wilson was allowing the child to run with the wrong cloud. Her
ex-husband or ex-lover, the father of the child was worried about
this and was seeking custody and he was apparently
in that that child died in tragic circumstances.
>> I don't know. Does the truth hurt?
>> Dude, it's it's just painful to see you stoop so low
and I just can't figure it >> So low. >> Yeah. I
just can't figure it out. Like you came in clearly hostile. You
know, you didn't want to like you know, you came out trying to
measure your and it's like I I just don't I I don't understand
you. I'm >> I don't know why he said Rebel. Yeah, not Rebel
Wilson. No, not the person from
What's the What's the Chorus Line or the like the the cheer group?
No, no, no. The Glee Club show. The Glee Club movie that's really
popular. Ana
Kendrick.
It's uh Pitch Perfect. Yeah, Pitch Perfect. Not Rebel Wilson
from Pitch Perfect. No, I'm leaving. I'm done. Rachel and I'm
done with you, to be honest. >> Rage Quit. Oh man, dude.
Rage quit. I can't. You guys, I can't believe he rage quit. Oh
my lord.
Oh, that sucks, dude. I guess I win now. >> This guy sucks,
too. Oh well. I think Fentes did a bit of a defense for Richard
here. >> Yeah, you're just wrong about that. That's just
a LAR. Sorry, that's just a LAR conflated with being a
It's not about being a It's about then this happens in people's
lives. Two people find each other. It's never under ideal circumstances.
I think anybody would grow up and they want to marry their high
school sweetheart. Everybody wants to grow up and have a glamorous,
wonderful, beautiful life where nothing bad ever happens
and you you know you marry your first love. The super chat was
basically calling Andrew Wilson a for marrying his wife. And
Fent is gonna have the correct take, which is obviously you're
if you think that. And I don't even think Andrew's ever thought
that. And I think a lot of people who try to conflate that or
conflate him with Myron Gaines or somebody who would say that
are just stupid and low IQ and just want to dunk on him. But
hey, it's the same as like basically people who would call Destiny
call Hassan [__] like a socialist, like a a champagne
socialist. It's very very thin useless engagement from people
who are total cattle in all three of those cases. So of you have
lots of kids and you have a picture perfect life, but that's
not always how life goes. And sometimes for one reason or another,
people get older and they find people and they break apart or
they don't find somebody and they grow older.
And look what happens is is that people for whatever reason will
fall in love with each other. There'll be kids from a previous
relationship for one reason or another. Sometimes it's a widow.
Sometimes the husband dies under tragic
It's not always No, it's just like it's literally just dude,
if you if you have this kind of thing where it's like, oh, anybody
who's ever somebody who's been or somebody who has other kids
that like, oh, you're you're settling and that person's worthless
now. It's just like a horrible way to live your life or think
about anything. It's like a totally gay way to live your life.
It's It's just sad. >> The case that a woman is just >> It's
It's literally nobody who has any value of who values themselves,
who values anyone around them. Nobody has anything to look forward
to in life could ever have this outlook. It's only total losers.
It's the big It's the biggest losers on planet Earth who think
this way. And they just want everybody else to feel as bad about
their lives as they do. All of these people >> just sleeping
around. Sometimes there's legitimate circumstances.
There's domestic abuse. These things do happen.
And then you might find a guy who, you know, let's face it, guy's
getting older, can't find a wife, finds a nice enough, decent
woman, she's got kids, and yeah, it actually does take a lot
of integrity and it does take a lot of self assuredness
and I think piety to step in and have love for those children
and not resent them because you you can be mad that your situation
is not ideal. You can be mad that you didn't have the picture
perfect life, which we I think all would agree is ideal. I think
>> this is my exact take and Fuentes has it. This is my
exact take, right? Yeah, dude. There's so many things you could
actually hate Andrew Wilson for. Why hate him for like the one
good thing that you know he's done, which is step in and raise
those kids and actually love his kids as if they love his wife's
kids as if they were his own.
It's like the one thing you actually shouldn't [__]
on him for. It's like the one thing you know he's like a good
person for doing. And people take that one thing and on that
it's like dude you're you're just a you're worthless >> and
I think piety to step in and have love for those children and
not resent them because you you can be mad that your situation
is not ideal. You can be mad that you didn't have the picture
perfect life- which we I think all would agree is ideal. I think
anybody would would agree the ideal is that you fall in love
with your wife. You know you're both virgins. You have kids.
They're your biological kids. I think anybody would agree that
is that is the way anybody would want their life to go. But that's
not always how it happens
because life is complicated
and people are complicated and sometimes people have a ciruitous
road to happiness to their family and it actually does take a
ton of integrity and that actually is real Christlike
to marry a woman and if she has kids treat them as the innocent
children they are and love them because they need a father not
resent them because
they threaten your ego or challenge your ego. So, don't don't
give me this, you know, it's wrong. Come on. Don't give me
>> this is this is like the only real take here. And it's
just sad that a lot of people can't see that. There's so many
things to [__] on the guy. >> Yeah. Come on.
That's a lot of nonsense. And um you know, look, every child
deserves a father. A lot of people don't have a father, would
like a father, and it shouldn't be taken out on the children.
So, that's all a lar. And I'll say something else. I do believe
in Jesus Christ. I do believe in mercy. I do believe in forgiveness.
I do believe in charity and magnanmity and grace. These are our
values. This is what it is to be good. You know, these other
people that are talking down on that are not role models. They're
not role models. They're not people that I admire. They're not
people that have a lot of integrity themselves.
So, I really I really don't like this. Shouldn't have to do with
Christianity, by the way. You should literally just as any any
religion, as any ideology, you should be able to see somebody's
doing something good. It is good for the world. It is something
you should support and you shouldn't talk it.
That's just the way it is.
You're a worthless loser if you think otherwise >> that
people are going after. I mean, listen, I don't agree with Andrew
Wilson on everything.
You know, him and I, we obviously have somewhat different. We
agree on a lot of things. We >> I have one cut out and
that's for Tree of Logic cuz Andrew Wilson and her go at each
other like honey badgers. Okay, that's like the one cut out I
have. Tree can Tree can say whatever and I'm not going to judge
Tree for that cuz Andrew goes back at her heart the other way.
Okay, but other than that, in a real sense, it's not something
you should >> Somewhat different politics. But that actually
is a decent man. That is actually a good man. He's got a good
wife. They have a nice family. He's doing the right thing. He's
being a father for fatherless children. That's commendable. And
not everybody can do that. Not everybody would do that. But it
takes a lot of integrity for him to do that and he should be
admired for that. Not not ridiculed, not made fun of. People
shouldn't shouldn't glibly say that's gay, that's being cucked.
You know, I think that's very cheap and it's very low. It's very
easy to say that, especially if you're somebody that is not very
responsible yourself. Not for nothing, but consider the source.
I you know, I don't I don't like that. I I saw the first clip
where Spencer and him had a disagreement about the rules. I didn't
see the final clip where Spencer's making fun of their dead child.
As if that >> Did Spencer go that far? I didn't even see
we didn't get to that point. >> As if that has any quarter.
As if that that should be tolerated in any way. >> He's
saying the parents were reckless. That's why their kid died.
Why go there? That is so that is so wicked and so wrong. And
for people to think that's funny or people think that's banter,
I really question whether you have a conscience.
And you know me, I'm a troll. I like to have fun. I think things
are funny. But that's just that's just so beyond the pale.
And then to throw out, oh, that's gay, that's cucked. You know,
that's easy to say
when you know you're you're living like you think you're a rock
star living an irresponsible life of your own and everybody else
supposed to pick up the pieces. the fatherless children, the
women without a man. You know, we're all supposed to pick up
the pieces for the rock stars that that that think that's >> I
really hate when the die for Nick guy moralizes to me, moralizes
at me. I mean,
can't you just look at when he says that and say I disagree and
then look at when he says something correct and say I agree.
Like, if you want to give an argument back against this, you
don't like argue against it. Argue against what I said that it's
just an objectively good thing that should be
just it makes the world better. If everybody acted the way Andrew
Wilson did with regards to basically loving his stepkids the
way he loves his actual kids. If everybody acted that way, the
world would just be a better place. It's laudable behavior. It's
it's always good
It's categorically good behavior.
Why [__] on somebody for categorically good behavior?
It doesn't make any sense to me, my opinion. Well, I you know
that was implied when I said to me >> and that's cucked
and that's for losers and that that's for losers that love people.
I mean you know that's no way to live. So I just really question
you know who are the role models going to be.
It's f it's funny. It's cute. It's funny. Uh but he's being selectively
virtuous. Okay that's finally one good criticism. Okay I guess
maybe Vegeta Data is saying the same thing here. I think he's
kind of cynical. If Andrew Wilson was on Nick, I do think Nick
would say, "Yeah, you you got that kid killed or something."
Okay,
I do think that's probably true. But >> who's the real
role model there? I think Andrew Wilson's a real role model,
actually. I think he's actually the upstanding guy. And I say
that with no animosity, but I didn't like that. And that was
wrong. You know, that was wrong. We should be able to say with
conviction, that's wrong. And I don't think that sets a very
good example, actually. I don't think that's cool. And I don't
think it's funny. You know, I like Spencer. He's a friend of
mine. I like his content. I think he's got some interesting ideas.
But that was wrong. It was wrong and it was it was wrong. And
if you have a conscience, you should be able to differentiate
between those things. Okay, you disagreed about the format of
the debate. You bring their dead kid into it. What does the matter
with you? Who says something like that? It's just not right.
So anyway, so I had a big problem with that. I didn't see that
clip and that's why I had to speak. That's why I had to say something
today. I don't want to, you know, intervene in another debate,
intervene in another drama, but now I saw somebody say, "Oh,
yeah, he's a gay. Oh, that's real masculinity." It's like, okay,
this is a Christian movement. Those are the I'm a Christian.
You have a problem with that, you Christian.
And this is a Christian movement. We're not about to lose ourselves
to that kind of mentality. It's not right.
>> So, after Fentes responded the way he
>> Richard Spencer went on the kill stream.
with Ethan Ralph
to give his opinion on that defense. Okay.
Was not a fan. >> The moral high ground does kind of like
Okay. I >> It's a bit much. I mean, what was it like two
days ago that Nick was
[laughter] James Fishbach like as a sociopath? He's like, "Yes,
he is evil. That's why we should support." I mean, you can't
just go back and forth on these things. And I could find other
examples. I was just looking
>> Uh so also I'm not aware of any lost children that Nick
has adopted. I know there's some Down Syndrome [laughter] uh
children out there just waiting for a father and uh I haven't
heard yet of whether he's adopted, but he could do the coolest
thing ever right now and adopt a Downey. That's what he could
do. I mean, it's obviously saying that he wouldn't want to do
that and it takes somebody to do that. Takes like a certain kind
of person, but okay. >> Um, let let me
Ralph is funny. >> Let me say one thing. Uh, and first
off, I don't hate I I still like Nick, too. And actually, >> I'm
I'm I'm cool with push back, but I can push back as well. >> That's
right. >> Now, let me let me say something about the Oh
my god. Oh,
I'm cool with push back, but I could push back as well. Famous
last words, man. I don't know how that's >> your responsibility,
which he didn't mention my name, but I it's sort of what
>> Richard is having a child with Radfam Hitler, who lost
custody of her previous child, rumored because of abuse. I have
no idea why she lost her previous child. I do know Radfam Hitler
got by Sarah Stark's new husband, so I don't know. I that's going
to be weird for Richard, I'm guessing. But
dude, the whole right-wing influencer sphere is just this inetuous
orgy. It's very weird. Okay, are we serious? I've heard this.
I've heard this. I'm not joking. I've heard this. I can't remember
who said it, but the whole right-wing influencer sphere is just
like nothing but DGens. Okay. Tons and tons of Dgens.
>> You're Mark Carney supporter. >> Yes. I am not
a perfect person within that imperfect world that I live in.
I absolutely take responsibility for my children and I am deeply
invested in their lives.
So,
you know, I I don't know what to say. In some ways, I'm living
the dream in the sense that this is great and it works. So, I
sorry. Uh, I mean, I spend more time
like taking my >> You're like, I'm living the dream right
now. You sure about that? >> Daughter to a ballet performance
or throwing a baseball with my son. Then most all gropers, including
Nick
>> Well, he definitely does not do. >> You can take
that for what it's worth. Just is what it is. I'm not But I'm
not perfect, but I'm also not not a moralist. I like to see things
as they are and not as they should be. Um, but the there's an
interesting interesting thing that he said in their
>> So, RFH was actually talking to me about how Rachel
made a comment on Twitter about how so many >> So, he's
dating RFH then. Is that like open that they're dating or because
he's mentioned her like
14 times now. in the 20 minutes I've watched them.
It's a lot of mentions. >> Many great men marry widows
with children or something. I
>> That word that word stuck out to me. And I wonder if
she's feeding him things on on the DMs, these like talking points.
This sounds like some moralizing church lady. This does not sound
like the Nick Fuentes that I know and love who's actually cool
and edgy. This sounds like the church lady. >> We have
problems. Yeah, for sure. Yeah. >> I I just genuinely think
it's Richard being so emotionally disregulated.
>> That's what makes it weird for him. Like that's what
makes the comments weird. It's like you you were just generally
trying to do harm. You're not like a
doesn't give a guy. You're like someone who's like, "Well, if
you're just going to leave and make me look dumb, then I'm going
to say things that hurt you and that's like not cool. There's
just nothing cool about that or respectable about that." You
know what I mean? Once you're like flustered and you're angry,
saying these things carry a different connotation.
You're not like some edgy guy who's making funny jokes. You're
some like emotionally dregulated loser who's
having a midlife crisis. Like very different energies. >> Yeah.
But she's not a widow. Okay. >> No, she's not. >> Uh
she is a patriot.
Um [screaming] who was wildly rambunctious
and was >> who I just broke up with and said by the way,
but anyway. Yeah. Go ahead. >> She was getting pregnant
by multiple men and she found a loser dork whom she could force
her children on to. I'm sorry. I'm And what's different for Richard?
Is it that that the girl he's seeing is already lost custody
of her children? Is that the only difference? That she wasn't
a good enough mom to keep custody of her children or I that seems
to be the only difference, right, between him and Andrew Wilson?
Oh, and probably about a couple million dollars. >> Sorry,
but like that I I the other thing that stuck out was laring.
Laring. Well, I I think you're kind of laring by pretending that
the Wilsons are a traditional family. That's the LAR. >> That's
stupid. >> They're not. In any other culture, she would
be a Oh, Richard Spencer is a trust fund. She has money. How
much money does he have? I know he cames I know he he came from
money. Comes from money. Came from money. I know he cames from
money,
but is he really
does he have that much left?
Feels like if you got a lot of money,
are you showing up on the killstream late night?
Is that
is that what you do with your your your trust fund? You go in
the killstream late night. >> Ostracized from society.
>> Period. End of statement. In the 20th century, she would
be ostracized from society. Period. End of statement. The only
society where she can make a living as an egrifter is actually
our post feminist one. this one. Yeah.
>> Period. End of statement. There's no there's no controversy
about that. That's just simply a fact. Um, so yeah, she's Hold
on. Hold on. Did you see those sick moves from Ralph right there?
>> Okay. I was eating some food. Good now.
See those sick moves?
>> Period. End of statement. There's no there's no controversy
about that. That's just simply a fact. Um, so yeah, she's a bird
and she put her eggs in someone else's nest. That's what it is.
That's the reality of the situation. That's no lar.
>> Um,
on another matter,
I by no means
made fun of their dead child.
In fact, I took the side of their dead child. I was taking his
side and I was also taking the side of the child's husband which
is not Andrew by the way his name is Brian Jennings
and he was filing with the court for emer I >> think she
he means like Rachel Wilson's
not the child's husband surely surely >> protective orders
for his child this is a fact >> that um tree of logic actually
did a lot of research and this is not disputed by them. So, I
take it as a fact. Now, it's hard to get that stuff done. You
know, some you could go to a court and say, you know, oh, I I
need a um a protective order against Ethan Ralph, you know, because
he's he's on me on Twitter. You might not get it. Like, [laughter]
they don't always give it to
>> It's happened before. Yeah. >> So, they did not
give an emergency protective order for Brian to gain temporary
custody of his biological son.
>> Uh, and
a short time afterwards,
this child died who was 10 years old who was being driven in
a car [snorts] by a
Now, what happened? I don't know. I don't know what happened
exactly, but this sounds very bad and this sounds like neglectful
parenting
to be honest.
I mean, at the very least, the question can be asked in this
case,
you know, and like you you hear about like child protective services
uh overreach, you know, like um parents let their kids go unsupervised
to the park or whatever and they get called up and you hear horror
stories like that. Well,
something is going wrong. Brian Jennings was worried about his
biological son uh running with the wrong crowd and he wanted
a protective order. That wrong crowd got his son killed. Now
the the young man who
I mean you'd have to do a little more work than just that. I
understand that you know it's all court papers and whatever.
You'd probably have to figure out exactly what was going on there.
Does this Jennings guy like actually believe this? Ralph hitting
the emotes. Dude, I I would just wonder because I'm You can say
all of this and these are like the circumstances, but you don't
know exactly what happened here that this kid got in a car with
a 14-year-old or something. I
uh it's it's so tough to say what happened there. That's why
like basically if this were the case, I would hope that the biological
father would press charges, right? And if the biological father
didn't press charges, I'm guessing he understood what was going
on, right? Yeah. If like, dude, this could happen. Yeah. Southern
smash. This could happen. Like you could you could keep an eye
on your kids. Your kids could grab the keys to your car and sneak
out. I drove my parents' car into the side of our house like
trying to back out of the driveway when I was like 10 years old.
I I decided I could do that on my own. I'd already done it once
or twice with them in the car and I ended up like swerving the
vehicle into the side of the house and like breaking this the
siding off of the house.
Like I that like that happens with kids, right? It could happen.
So, you just don't know. Like, you don't know. And I don't think
bringing up somebody's pain when you really don't know is appropriate.
[clears throat] >> I I have contact by the way. You know,
this debate should have happened on the stream, right? And we
talked about we dude Ethan Ralph,
you know, this debate should have happened on the stream, right?
Oh, yeah. We know Ethan, we know you would have been a great
moderator, Ethan.